I mentioned previously that you
shouldn't add tab index to site
content as a general rule.
But there is one exception to this and
that's when you're manipulating
the page, in response to a user action.
A scenario might be that a user goes and
clicks on one of these menu items.
And the page then does an animated
scroll, down to that particular section.
Or, if you are building
a single page web app,
clicking on one of the navigation
links changes the content of the page
without doing a full page refresh.
In either of these situations, you'll
want to pick an appropriate header,
give the tab index of negative one so it
doesn't appear in the natural tab order,
and call its focus method after
the user has taken their action.
This process is known as Managing Focus,
and
it's an extremely important technique
that keeps the user's interactive
context in sync with the visual
representation of the site.
Let's go through that single page
app scenario I just discussed and
I'll highlight what happens
when we don't manage focus.
And then demonstrate how the experience
can be improved when we do manage focus.
So here we are back at our site.
I'm going to go click on this.
What is Vegemite link?
And when I do that I'm going to
want to start clicking around some of
the anchors in the main page content.
So using my keyboard,
I'll navigate over there.
I'll press enter.
And now I'd like to click this link.
But in order to get there I'm going to
have to tab back through my navigation.
Now, there's only a few
navigation items here.
So it's not the biggest
deal in the whole world.
But you can imagine on a complex site
with a lot of navigation going on in
the header, that could be a lot of
work to get through all of that.
Furthermore, as a screen reader user,
I might not even know that the page
content has loaded in and changed yet.
I may just be sort of
sitting around waiting for
something to happen after
I've clicked that link.
Let's see if we can improve
upon this a little bit.
So what I'm going to do is,
take this heading right here.
I'm going to give it a tabindex of -1.
If you recall, that means the element
won't be in the tab order, but
I can programmatically
focus it using JavaScript.
Now, I can listen for my anchor clicks.
I can tell the page content to update.
And lastly, I can call the focus
method of that header.
Once I've done that, the user
will then be moved down in here,
inside of our main page content,
and then can then quickly Tab,
or Shift+Tab to whatever they want.
So let's run through that.
I'm going to go over to
the recipe section, hit Enter.
You'll see the header is focused, and
I can very quickly jump down into
these additional anchor links.
Now you might notice that as we do this,
the header itself gets a large
focus ring placed around it.
I'm going to talk more about
styling focus in a future lesson.
But if you'd like, you can click
the link down in the instructor notes to
jump ahead and
learn how to work around this issue.